a lot of the conversation has been both
in on television and in film how police
are portrayed in entertainment have you
thought about that at all you know I've
played I played my handful of cops my
share of cops yeah police and I played
my share of characters who have met
their fate at the hands of police you
know I think of like I mean it would be
the obvious connection or current
connection would be SVU this abuse of
power sickens me I think one of the
things that I'm excited about where it
pertains to as for you and their
portrayal of not only cops but also also
victims of crime is that they've never
been opportunistic in the way that they
go about depicting stories from the
headlines and I have the utmost
confidence that they will be artful and
compassionate and sensitive in the way
that they go about doing that in this
coming season I can't make this go away
if you can't
and our relationship is over if you sort
of started to shark the things the
changes that maybe you will make or the
things that you will maybe push a little
bit harder for moving forward great
question
I've been thinking about race as it
pertains to my career and I think very
early on in my career
I was already making choices and
decisions in lieu of not only the story
that needed to be told but the stories
that I needed to tell given where I find
my unique place within it so that
influenced my my choices and decisions
very early on I found myself turning
down things where people are like how
who are you to be turning down this role
to play this black man in fill in the
blank
you know let's say stereotypical
situation I think going forward I think
I'm just gonna really continue that I'm
gonna continue to lean into that